Hello, welcome to class everybody. My name is David Brown. This is a grammar class. Hello. Welcome. Welcome to class. Norma. Welcome. Hello. Thank you. How are you? I'm doing good. How are you? I'm doing great. Thank you.
Norma, did you have a good weekend? Yes, I had* a good weekend with my family.
Great. Excellent. Did you spend time with, you have a son, right? His name is Jose Pablo? Yes. He always tries* to play with me. So I can do anything at home about just playing with him.
Okay, that does sound like a good weekend. In this lesson, Norma, we're going to talk about weekends and we'll talk about regular and irregular verbs, the difference between those two.
And how to describe our weekends using pronunciation and also sequence adverbs. Let's read these objectives here. Can you see the screen, okay? Yes, I can see it.
Okay, great. Let's start by reading this part right here. Can you read this line for me? Talk about the past. You see all past verbs like washed, went, ate.
to describe finished events. Okay. And the next one? And then the next order. Order your story. Use special words. First, then, next. After that, finally, to tell things in the right order.
Sound clear, practice saying -ed verb endings correctly. Okay. And write your story. Write a short paragraph, three to five sentences about a personal past event.
Okay, great. So these are our goals for today's lesson.
We see that we have the past, the present, and the future. We have different conjugations and many students struggle with the past tense quite a bit for two reasons: One, there are different ways to pronounce verbs that end in ED.
And also because there are so many irregular past tense verbs, probably more than 200 irregular past tense verbs that we need to memorize.
So we see that the basic verb structure is basically verb plus ed. And that's the simple past. And that works most of the time. So we just add ed to the end of it. For example, we have finished and in the past, it is finished.
A base verb, and then the rest. Here's an example here. Can you read this example for me?
Present, watch TV, past, yesterday, I watched* a movie.
Okay. Good. We're going to practice some pronunciation a little bit more. It could be difficult for native Spanish speakers to pronounce that ch sound in watched.
But you'll get it. Don't worry.
And so we see an example like this one, too. They play soccer. And then in the past becomes they played soccer. And you can hear a different pronunciation for this one.
In the first one, a /t/ sound, the second one, a /d/ sound. And then here's another example. Can you read this one for me?
She cooks dinner past she chicken dinner last night.
Great. So the basic spelling rules are that we need to add ed to the end of the verb.
There are some times when we need to change the y to i and then add ed. For example, study becomes studied or cry,
becomes cried  with i ed.
But most of the time, you'll just add -ed to the end of the verb to make it past tense.
All right. Let's continue. Do you have any questions for me before we continue on?
No, I just want to, as you mentioned, it is difficult. This is one of the most difficult parts when I start learning English, the past tense because of that pronunciation part.
But we try practicing and practicing.
I understand. And it's normal to feel a little bit nervous when we try to do difficult things.
So far, you're doing really, really good exceptional. So don't worry, Norma.
All right. So one challenging thing, as you mentioned, is knowing all of these are regular verbs.
And so we need to memorize them. There really is no way around memorizing these different verbs.
Of course, we need to use them in context, but we really need to memorize all of these irregular past tense verbs.
So we have some examples here. The past tense of go is went...the past tense of eat is ate.
The past tense of have is had* the past tense of see is saw past tense of drink is drank past tense of make is made.
Good pronunciation. The past tense of buy is what? Bought.
Oh, okay. And how about this one?
Past tense of wake up is woke up.
All right. And then we need to remember these conjugations for the verb to be.
So not only do we have a regular one, sometimes they look totally different in past tense conjugations.
So we have be and then was or were for the word to be.
All right. So these are just a small sample of irregular verb.
I really recommend that when you have time, try to find lists of these irregular verbs and use them.
Think about them whenever you speak about the past. Make sure that you're conjugating them correctly.
Let's test a couple of these. And I think we can continue on because you're doing really well.
The past tense of go is went the past tense of have is had the past tense of drink is drank.
Good. The past tense of buy is... Bought?
Wow. Okay. Your pronunciation really has improved a whole lot. I'm really impressed.
Thank you.
All right. So we have three different ways that we pronounce these verbs that end in -ed.
And we've had some implicit practice with this before, but I think it's really useful to understand some of these rules too.
We have three different sounds that we make whenever we pronounce verbs that end in -ed.
One is with a /t/sound here with your teeth.
The other one is with a /t/ sound and it's behind the teeth right there in the alveolar ridge, it's called.
That's where we pronounce the d-d sound. And then we have the id sound.
So it starts with this vocal sound here is where vowels come from.
And then it ends with the dip sound in the roof of your mouth.
So we have dip and id and it depends on the final consonant.
So the final consonant sound of watch, for example, is ch repeat repeat repeat.
There you go. Very good. All right. So we have watched? This one's very difficult.
Watched? Watched? Watched? Watched? Very good.
Great. And look becomes. Look.
Looks very good. Stop is. Stop. Right. So we don't have a sound that starts here with the a /t/ at the end.
And then we have the d sound. Remember in the roof of the mouth.
So we have play in the past becomes remember /d/. Repeat after me.
Very good. Played. Played.
Good. This one? Opened.
Great. And this one?
Lived. Wow. Perfect. Awesome.
So you can memorize these rules here.
You can learn them after some time of just practicing and hearing them for a long time.
But if you remember that if it starts or rather if the final consonant is L B and B G M R Z or J,
then it will result in that /d/ sound at the end.
The most important rule to remember is that when the final consonant is "t" or "d",
then we're going to pronounce the -id at the end.
So we have wanted in the final consonant is "t".
wanted it's wanted the final consonant of need is what? Needed.
So it's D. The final consonant is D. So it's needed and decided.
Decided. Perfect. All right. So we add an extra syllable with that id sound at the end.
I think we can continue on. How do you feel?
Does this seem easy to you or is it a little too difficult or what do you think?
I think you're doing great.
No, I feel comfortable.